okay viewer tournament time let's do
preparation for tomorrow's bitcoin
tournament
let's make a two minute chest
i know that's kind of fast for some
people but
i kind of want to prepare
and i'm gonna practice berserking every
game
so i do get the question a lot what is
berserking
i should answer this thoroughly before
the tournament begins
berserking is where you start with less
time
basically you start with half your
original time so
um
when i berserk i'll start with one
minute rather than two
and if i win the game
i'll get an extra tournament point for
the standings
so it's explained here
um it is risky but
maybe make things more fun
five
four
three okay good luck everyone
zero
hey playing full down okay
oh full dan knows uh
knows my stafford
do i play it anyway
oh i know it'll play
oh i don't know what they'll play
wait play knight g5 i want to play
tracks for now
ah i know knight g5
okay
now we have some
strange opening
i'm up a pawn though
this position feels pretty nice
i think i would like to take
wow g4
okay so i'm going to win the d4 pawn
after the knight moves
or not
that was a bit nifty
and queen f6 holding on to f3
i could have traded queens but
wow after pawn jake's b7 i played this
and the the white queen was almost
trapped there
okay now queen h4 is coming
like the queen has to move here i think
if bishop here i take
okay up a bishop
didn't quite get my mating attack i was
hoping for
but got some endgame
still takes some work to win though
trying to open things up
especially the g file
yeah white was running made in one there
okay i want to play this and this
f3 can be pre-moved
actually bishop e4 is a maybe a bigger
threat
um
okay i wanna
wanna infiltrate somehow
hey this is a fun looking move
so i have connect three
where's my mate
what is this position
check
i don't see my mate
ah the king is so slippery
where's my meat
we repeated some weird way too
there we go
okay
plenty of time
always play bishop f8 techniques
okay what the start to the tournament
good game pool dan
i was almost fooled
oh that king was like doused in oil
i was trying to catch it but it kept
slipping away
so yeah again continuing berserking
actually i
feel like it's easier to berserk
in a two-minute time control than a
one-minute time control
it's nice for having a minute compared
to 30 seconds
okay ponziani time
bishop c5 only made d4 stronger
i'll defend the pawn
f5 very fine move
i want to play knight e5
especially at bishop g4
and now if takes takes the problem for
black is a knight in the pawn
i think this is okay so takes takes
takes rook c1 queen a5
oh and then queen c4
oh i miss that move
okay i'll still win c7 or not
black had rook f7 there
uh i guess i'll take in king f1
okay i'm going to try and employ the
carlson endgame strategy
of
activating the king and then mating the
opponent
yeah g6 was a bit weakening
wait where's my mate
check
uh oh
this isn't so clear
i have to run all the way back
okay i'll walk back to c3
there we go
put the rook on c2
it's going to require some technique
here
hiding my king
starting made in two
okay i'm up three pawns now
gradually
moving up
in the world
okay i'll meet with king and rook
okay every game i have like two or three
seconds left man
good game to my opponent it was a close
one
thank you adfoss gifting to johnny d
okay
so six tournament points
keeping up my berserk streak
playing liquid yxng
i'll be zerk again
play one of these
opponent moving quickly
[Music]
oh no white's queen
i think my opponent was anticipating
queen e7 and not bishop e7
or maybe it was very tilted
okay uh well i'll move on
i'm in first place now let's go
i'll play a london
yeah so if i wasn't berserking i would
have like three less points i think
i know again mata recommends this
anti-london idea
but uh yeah 93 is a nice response
now knight g5
is actually a
kind of common london trap
get both knights
to attack f7
again if you want to join
link is shared by nightbot
you can use the join command
might have to scroll up to find the link
rook's attacked
can take it
and knight will eventually come back
but it's having a nice vacation
[Music]
yeah opponent saw this but didn't
probably see this
okay
last two games were pretty efficient
so some players somewhat close behind
playing yayab berserking back
have a b3
yeah i want to make a sharp castle queen
side
go for
[Music]
some eventual
[Music]
uh yeah let's do this
so i win the queen
and then the knight is going to be
hanging two
[Music]
after white takes on d1
or takes on g4 i take and then take
oh i can also take again and then take
so this worked out really nicely
rook t2 i check and win the pawn
ah i didn't see that move
i think i have to take
i mean i could take but
it should still be better for me
yeah i allowed the counter tactic
play c5 and go for b5
also preventing b4
so if white wants to defend i mean
knight a5 b6
okay
pawns go marching
i'll clean up the pawn first
okay
let's go
20 points
no mercy
yeah welcome to all the new people it's
not too late to join
nice thing about doing an arena
tournament you can join
or
pause whenever
or rage quit whenever
let's play a walrus
wins the pawn right away
um
yeah it's kind of a risky opening but
leads to kind of an interesting position
white's playing very natural moves and
getting a clear advantage
hey it's cc hustle
thanks for the raid
for those just joining i'm running a
viewer tournament
it's a two-minute bullet chess
we started
about 10 minutes ago
the tournament link is in the chat you
can use the join command
shout out to cc hustle appreciate the
raid
this is in preparation for the ogen
mater bitcoin tournament tomorrow
which uh yeah has a massive prize fund
okay let's move this move
okay let's be safe
white's playing this well
but okay i feel like i've stabilized a
little bit
not getting mated
got a nice e5 square and g3 square
lockheed on the dark squares
the queen might want to infiltrate
further
bring the rook to g8
so i'm still down a pawn i haven't won a
single pawn yet but i'm going to be
winning upon
or multiple pawns uh very soon
inducing this to play this
g2
[Music]
so if white tries to take and then
defend i take here because then there'd
be a pin
i have 19 seconds
yeah plenty of time
i just want to simplify
rook is now pinned
okay finally up on time
also up a lot of pawns
okay
no mercy
so 31 minutes left
almost out of t
not sure if i'll have any tea left by
the time this tournament ends
will magnus be joining the agent macho
arena i don't know
it's possible though
i think it's more than 50 likely
okay double berserk
this is a fun line
so i get the bishop here
queens are off the board but
okay i'll win a pawn here
avoiding the rook trade
i'd like to try and complete development
yeah i'll go for h5
i think the king
oh king d2 there would be bishop e4
okay let's trade all the rooks
checked deflecting the king away from
defending the pawn
i missed a fork
uh
oh can i be really fancy i can be really
fancy
oh no my rook
i'm gonna be down a minor piece in the
end of this
but i have g6 and the pawn is queening
yeah i went for the style points there
okay that was nice keeping up the best
work streak
oh that one game
i won in like six five or six moves it
didn't count for bizwerking because
the game was so short
other games i got five points for
oh opponents going for this uh this h5
dirty trap
okay so against h5 i usually like to
just go into a queen's gambit
where box kind of committed to moving
the pawn
okay i think i'll try and develop
normally
this is a lingering weakness
if 97 i think i would take
some idea to target the file as well
never mind
okay oops actually a solid position
kind of for both of us
black castle's queen side go for
minority attack
i'm delaying castling because
i'm content with my king here
idea of this or this
maybe this
try and get rid of the knight
and then yeah we trail and see never
mind
okay i guess now i'll have good knight
versus bad bishop
idea d5 soon
so if takes i take with discover check
um i think i can take here
so if takes i check
maybe we're just trading
um
ah my time i'm spending too long
[Music]
okay rook
d4 okay with a pawn here
okay this should be winning
king's a little bit out of it but
this better be winning
four months pog
so basically what's happening is black
is in perpetual zigzag
just wait for the pawns to push
there we go
i'll clean up the ponds
okay it felt pretty clean
hey happy four months jacob garrett's
okay
feeling clean
how many points have i gained
i've gained three points from all these
games
yeah i'm risking a lot
oh let's play the jonathan trance uh
what is this
i think he called it the tan gambit
jonathan trans has like a new video
about this
and it looked interesting
i don't think e3 is a common move
i already like the position
nice and open bishops can develop
uh
that's a reasonable move
develop and defend
hey jonathan's in the chat
shout out to jonathan
i'll try and make you proud
okay eyeing the c2 square
so it's completely symmetrical pawn
structure
but now
yeah white's gonna have a weakness
yeah very small edge for black
just because of this pawn
i was hoping for a more tactical crazy
battle but
this is now very positional and
technical
[Music]
always trying to exploit this pawn but
it's very well defended
i'm taking rookie one
actually that blunders upon
you have to be careful here
so i'm up upon
which is usually enough to win an
endgame
but it does require patience
and the goal is to trade all the rooks
and also activate my king
i want to bring the king to a3
i win this pawn
yeah usually the rook and pawns can just
like kind of caterpillar their way up
the board
it's hard for white to do much
like you contract and then you expand
contract
expand
and then you turn into a butterfly
okay that was pleasant
40 points
captain
moist nuclear redeeming sip tea
we have 22
minutes left and some change
no mercy this tournament playing freebo
in second place ooh
decently rated too
playing against a dutch
so this is a the g4 gambit
ah this line i remember this line h5 is
a funny move
i actually prepared this exact move
against augustine
in the 2018 extracon open in denmark
um
i was kind of expecting some weird move
order dutch but it didn't happen in the
game
so
wow what a position
what is this position i think i'll take
and play queen d3
iron queen g6
develop the bishop
okay threatening bishop e4 knight e7
[Music]
i'll play this because now the idea is
to take deflect the bishop
and then target c7
maybe this move first
man it's a funny position got my knight
to a happy place
b7 is undefended but
oh b2 is hanging
what's going on here
c3 looks solid i just want to castle and
be happy
let's defend also don't want a flag
i should have probably taken that
queen e4
uh 24 26.87
hitting the bishop i might lose a knight
in the end but if the king goes back i
check
there we go g5 is now hanging
with check
and box kind of crumbling here
i'll simplify
down a lot of time
oh i pre-moved e3 almost allowing rig h1
okay it's time to pre-move
a lot of these moves are safe free moves
meaning that there's no way for a block
to actually exploit
the fact of like what i'm about to do
the trick is to make sure everything's
defended
okay the trick is also not to stalemate
yeah i could try king a1 coming
yeah so fun fact after b4
on poisson is illegal because it's check
and then c4 a very explosive mate
okay it was kind of a cool game
it was a really cool opening actually
okay
45 tournament points playing magnus is
my second
that would be cool to have magnus as a
second
how do i play against carol khan
i'll play d3
it's been a pet line of mine for a bit
okay resembles some king's indian setup
more on the solid side
i want to play this eventually
some bishop a3
i'm gonna try and play on both sides of
the board
and get the left right hook
kind of like boxing
okay defend the pawn
wait that's a free queen
i saw the pawn was attacked i was
looking for ways to defend
this was the ultimate way to defend
okay 50 tournament points
so i've gained
i try not to be too fixated on rating
but i've gained five points
from 11 games
keeping my berserk rates
what do i play against english
let's try and play this weird
whatever this is
um
i want to play something cool
nah let's just be normal
i'm gonna play like typical benoni ideas
knight d7 is very typical
and maybe
okay let's play a4 first
bishop g6 and f5 perhaps coming
threatening to trap the knight
okay some idea to play e4
sometimes this is overextending but i
think in this case it's pretty strong
reinforced with the rook
and the knight
man there's so many ways to have fun
here
looking at taking an e3
i'll play c6 first undermine the bishop
um
okay defending again
trying to be patient
queen d5 maybe
ah the knight's coming in my crib
uh
played
this move i guess
very confusing position now
it might be losing a pawn
because takes takes and yeah d4 is
hanging
oh no my queen ah
i was gonna say oh no my pawn but my
queen just hung hail
42 months hell hey it's swollen steel
okay
i have to make toilet noggin proud
i just have the toilet noggin moment
primo bishop e4 maybe
g5 not looking so great
both rooks are hanging but i don't want
to take either of them
okay i'll take that one
finding this now
i had knight c okay i'll play nice for
the counter fork
that's such a good move
black was running or white was running
threatening me in all directions
don't hurt me
yeah my time okay that's my first loss
of the tournament
well played wagoner
i was a cool game until i
i lost a queen
and then lost on time
yeah welcome back to toilet nagin
uh
i appreciate the sub one of the ogs of
of the channel
so i'm at 50 points
i'm staying with my berserking uh
promise
playing this line
okay opponent gifted me some material
play bishop h6
queen d3 hitting the pawn
95
trying to maximize pressure here
and queen e2
[Music]
oh look at this move so it's a fork
and it's a discovery
where's my follow up it's a check
where's my follow up
ah this looks so fun
i think i'll play this move
threatening maiden one
and filling in the gap of the b8 square
if queen here i play this
oh that's a good move now my knight's
trapped
didn't really work
okay so i'm somehow up the exchange
still
locker's threatening deviousness
i have no time
[Music]
oh no
this isn't good
this is bad
oh no
ah
i was really hoping for the stalemate
trap
but it didn't happen
okay that's two losses in a row
uh let's try and recover
okay let's flip some more tea too
oh let's get revenge okay so i lost to
this player before
they played the english i'm going to
repeat the same opening
um
ah now we have an exchange slav
this time i'll try and play more solidly
and not plunder a queen
queen b3
or queen b6
i could play queen b3 but then maybe i
take
we can see a lot of trades coming
okay trying to pressure the pawn
e3 maybe i'll play h6 preparing g5
i can take in g5 and i think the
bishop's getting trapped
hitting stuff
it was not necessary to take on e2 but
free food
time is getting better
rook defends the night through x-ray
vision
while he was fighting maiden one
oh and threatening my other thing
okay this is not so clear anymore
[Music]
forcing a queen
trade i'm trying to defend everything
now
okay i hung a bishop but
white didn't take it
i want to play knight d4 probably
i want to take my own bishop
but i can't okay i'll take pawns now
threatening this fork
you might just kind of move one of these
oh it's a free rook
okay
got some revenge there
less than 10 minutes left
dojo cat
trying to fight ooh
dojo cat also berserking
never played dojo cap before
uh
that was a kind gift
i wonder if dojo cat is related to
chastojo
yeah i think queen c7 was a mouse up
there queen b6 was intended
stafford gambit time maybe
maybe not
d5 look feels weird to play d6 and then
d5 but
now the bishop's not defended this pawn
is pinned and attacked three times
knight is also kind of pinned to the
bishop
so black's under a bit of pressure
or white's under pressure i should say
i'm gonna sag in queen h4
might be reckless but it looks fun
pre-move this
okay i think this and this
do you have to be somewhat careful of
background made ideas
always bishop f8 if i need it
so there's king f2 here i think this is
uh
one of the only ways to defend
bishop h3 probably or knight c6
or bishop g4
i think knight c6 would be my choice
king e2 also but that walks into bishop
g4
wow
i didn't see queen f3 but yeah that uh
did lose material
i covered d8s
and now go for the
the pork
pin and fork
okay
60 points
playing freebo who also beat me earlier
wait no i'd be fibo earlier
i got confused
oh that was a c4 mate game
okay we'll have some
solid a little more typical like kind of
slower positional london
but white has a nice harmonious setup
i usually like to play a4
h3
slow playing a little bit
i want to play knight g5
f5 is some idea
[Music]
yeah very much a maneuvering game
not really threatening h5 might be
supporting this
okay didn't really make progress there
my queen should be back on b3
okay queen trade has happened
idea d5 now
my pawns should be on light squares to
compliment my my bishop
okay up upon still down on time
i feel a little bit pressured here but
c4 solves everything
i'll keep pushing
yeah i'll just keep pushing
ah i push too far the knight takes e7 i
have knight f7
black doesn't take it
12 seconds left
where's my knight go
by that face spike check
okay b3 is tender
oh good move
i lost the pawn no my pawns
here we go
one second
no seconds
you still need me please
please
yes
it's stalemates
okay
i was really close to flagging that game
i had to play a bunch of moves with no
time left
oh
okay
still in first
i lost some reading
playing magnus as my second again
playing on walrus
walrus declined
sacking this pawn
i'm inspired by magnus's play earlier
moving the h pawn
turning this now
oh i wasn't threatening this because uh
the rook was defended
okay so i'll take take there's some
potential queen sack from mate
never mind
or rook sack for
meat stalemate god
oh thank you about this up
it's not a true tournament without at
least one stalemate
so lights up two pawns here
but i'm trying to somehow break through
on the king side
not easy though
okay
oh i plundered a bishop but white didn't
take it
what is this position
i feel confused
oh no okay there's no queen a3
i think i can take this
if queen a2 i take and then mate
or if king f1 it's queen each one mate
queen h1 pre-movement
ah
not quite mate
there we go wait that's not me
so bla white could have taken here and
if i've removed this then i would have
gotten mated but okay very little time
so potentially one more game left
okay final game never played this
opponent before
i'm gonna try and
it might be hard to win before the
tournament ends
but we'll try
yeah white's playing well very solid
chess
doh my thing is trapped
okay so i'm down a piece and down a lot
of time
oh i don't want to end with a loss
i can win a pawn there
oh there's a trap it takes i play this
and the knight is lost
and the knight can't be defended
okay so white took the bait oh and now
i'm winning the bishop ii
[Music]
bishop d4 i have this move
wow turned around
offer the queen trade
and be aggressive here
a tournament is now over
and still take some work
rook d5
some 91 idea
in this move
i think this is okay
threading made in one
and that is useful on e1
[Music]
and now king here
and there's a few spike checks
okay
i think i can
breathe easy now
plenty of time
all right thanks for the game it's my
opponent
tournament's over
finished with 65 points
that was fun i hope people enjoyed that
got over 500 players
x5 sparks says around move 33 there's
some
[Music]
oh
move 33
wow
good catch
that's a nice tactic
rook d8
i basically have to take and i lose my
queen
yeah that would have been tragic
okay yeah there were probably a lot of
missed tactics in these games
but it was fun
thanks to everyone for playing and
watching
unfortunately i do have to go